boom so we're talking about losing
eyesight yes you you actually take
comfort in the fact that your eyesight
is starting to dwindle you want to chase
it at first I was like I'm fine
then I'm 42 then it's like let's try
some ones then it's 1 to 5 and then it's
1/5 so no I stopped because I have so
many [ __ ] glasses some of them are
ones some of them are 2 fives
it's like it's like you don't mean yeah
I dunno but what I appreciate is you
know where you're at by what you're able
to retain if you fight for it and the
things that are going no matter what you
do now I've heard there's some Israeli
guy who's got this app probably from
Laird got this app and you do it you get
your eyesight back and sometimes it's
about I don't need to try to use
something to hold on to everything I
want to pick the five or seven things
that I definitely want to hold on to and
I want to watch the rest of it go in and
out with the tides I agree with that in
some ways but if there was a real thing
where you could get your eyesight back I
would definitely be on that don't think
lasix
this is not real lasix but I know these
are real problems you can get it if you
have problems with your vision but we
have macular degeneration that's coming
from age age-related macular
degeneration lasix doesn't really fix
that but I know people who were wearing
glasses and then got lasix and they
don't wear glasses anymore that's that's
a fact
but also we never wore glasses they get
one eye to close up and one eye for
distance it's even more fun half the eye
exams I've gotten and wind-up [ __ ] me
two weeks later like these don't work
yeah what about the loss of a sense that
you are accustomed to being fine annoys
you what about it yeah I like being able
to see things read labels in particular
how many of these [ __ ] are supposed
to take know and what's in here yes how
many milligrams what's it say also this
[ __ ] but it's also funny to go up to
like a little Lutron pad and have to go
like that to me I just as a gas
really
interesting accept the things you cannot
change now if someone comes in and says
Joe Bob I got it we're done come over
here it's easy or it's a supplement or
do this for two weeks or stop doing this
this and this then there's a trade-off
yes
well I'm down for anything that actually
works to make your eyesight come back
but I have heard of nothing everybody
that I've heard of might be this might
be our project then because you care and
I don't so we have a nice balance
there's a guy named David Sinclair that
I talked to is a professor at Harvard
yes an American MIT where the [ __ ] is he
Harvard he's there doing some work with
people that have serious eye diseases
and serious injuries and they're
actually injecting some form of bacteria
that has been encoded with some miracle
cure for degeneration and they can
detach retinas fix things and incredible
yeah so they're working on some stuff
yeah so maybe in the future you won't
have to ones and one point fives and
yeah what am i God I've alighted to
greener pastures I'm sure there's going
to be other issues and hurdles that
you're gonna go iSight real going on
here yeah I'm sure - I'm concerned about
that do you that thing that you're
wearing around your neck yes being as
you are obviously known as being Ironman
are you concerned with wearing a large
thing in the exact same spot everything
that life is funny because I was doing
this before I ever got fitted for the RT
so it was more of our imitating oddball
stuff I was doing anyway oh really yeah
oh well it's even more interesting
because maybe you were born to be iron
man because iron man obviously had that
from the comic books loosely
pre-arranged destiny and what's
incredible is how far afield you can go
from it and still find your way back
yeah well there's been it's the the
whole superhero genre thing is so
interesting to me because there's so
many reboots and there's so many like
how many [ __ ] spider-man's have have
been how many Hulk's have there been
yeah there's only one Iron Man though
you got that thus far what yours is
here your iron man that looks like this
sir certain dudes just own a roll and if
anybody else tried to be Iron Man we
button well interestingly enough East
Coaster a dad of some renowned very
different my dad was a kind of a
underground filmmaker author maverick I
grew up definitely being Bob Downey's
seniors kid spent time on Long Island
which is I think where Tony was raised
yeah but when when Stanley was really
thinking that through he it was the
Vietnam era and he was thinking about
the military-industrial complex he was
thinking about how about if I can throw
a little bit of not politics in here but
karma and he gets shrapnel by the own
thing and it becomes you know so and
then of course there was the whole demon
in the bottle I think he was the first
superhero who ever like had that you
know almost like yeah hang up his jersey
because he's hammered yeah so I mean
yeah there was obviously but again once
something goes your way you can draw all
the parallels you want you can call it
destiny but it was it was something that
I definitely felt drawn to and I
definitely fought for and looking back
on and I go why was I fighting because
it turned out to be a pretty special
thing well it's an amazing thing I mean
you embodied it in a very strange way I
mean it's inexorable at this point you
you know which is why I thought it was
cool you're gonna do dr. Doolittle
because I love the fact I'm like I'm a
fan of your work you've done a lot of
great stuff like watch and you you doing
dr. Doolittle is like a cool it's I want
to say you're not taking yourself
seriously but you're taking your trust
that I'm not but you're taking I mean
this is a fun kids movie about a guy who
talks to animals yeah you know I mean
that's a great break for because like if
you're Ironman like there's certain
people that for whatever reason become a
role and that is it that's what we will
accept you
that guy and you're not doing that your
your you're able to through your talent
and through your ability to take chances
you're able to be a bunch of different
things as well as be the Iron Man yeah I
mean don't we I don't know if I'm
noticing anything now it's that it's
that we need to shift and we need new
challenges and just like MMA in society
and politics things are moving and
morphing and the information age is
making things so everything's learning
and growing from everything so quickly
and then improving or disproving or or
discounting whatever's happening next
but for me I heard that this was on the
table my missus who's my creative
partner in all things said Steve gig and
I was like I know Steve gig in Syriana
really what did he do he broke I like
that's a big turn for him yeah and then
I said but why why do I want to and I
looked out and we live on a on a rescue
farm we have real Packers and goats and
Cooney Cooney pigs and you know it's
just crazy and I was like okay same way
I did with Ironman a little bit I was
like all right there's something here
and then before I signed on I was just
googling like weirdest Welsh doctor I
just want to think of I don't want to
just do another English accent so
there's this guy William Price who's a
nutty Welsh doctor he was a neo druid st
was someone who believed like we could
communicate with all nature and all that
stuff so I sent a picture of this wild
looking guy wearing like a suit stars on
it and like a staff in his hand I sent
that to gig and he goes that looks right
to me I was like great let's do this
movie literally that's that it's always
it you know any mean it's always that
thing of you click and you go here's my
here's here's my sense what do you think
and and then the other the gal or the
guy says yeah let's lean into that and
then you go but do this and that anybody
give me some of this and you go yeah and
all of a sudden you're in a synergy it's
like a good interview like a good fight
like a good dinner
it's just kind of the gentleman right
there
that's a crazy look yeah to me I just
thought that's can do little be like
Daddy goes to so you have to be that way
the whole way through I go no no when
they find him he's a recluse and then
the animals like clean him up and then
he looks less fun handsomer would you
left less weird for the kids for the
rest of the movie but let's find him
like that this this concept of things
just sort of falling into place I'm a
big believer in that - what what is that
though is that you getting out of your
own way like what is that is it isn't
that 70% of it yeah yeah I say it's 70%
maintenance of what can I do to do my
part to stay out of the way and then the
other part I always think of it as like
this little super thin invisible thread
but you can feel the tug and you just
kind of you have to be really gentle and
you have to pause when agitated and you
have to go for it when you're gonna like
there's four walls in here which one has
the map behind at you it's that one and
you knock down the wall and it's there
you know yeah what is that though that's
a synchronicity yeah intuition but
labeling it it's very dangerous because
it's so filled with woo so it's you know
there's so many people that are
hucksters that have like made a career
out of sort of like labeling it and
defining it or teaching you how to get
to it it's great because it's the
commodity that you can't capitalize on
and yet if you don't show proof of its
existence you you can't even you
shouldn't even be qualified to speak on
it I don't know that's the big I don't
know but when it happens whether it
happens with love or with friendship or
with a career with a path you're taking
you just know while there's a smile
there's an inner smile like yeah this is
it well-put I found it this is it this
is it I'm supposed to be doing this here
we go here we go yeah and I really feel
it's so funny at this point in my life
and being you know kind of middle-aged
and all that well I know I'm gonna fly
around the world I'm gonna sell some
soap and I know I have a new project and
I know I've just retired my Jersey on
this 12-year journey
been on and and how do I want to start
and it came up how would you like it go
yes that's exactly what happened to I'm
gonna go have the Joe Rogan experience
and and kick off this year in this
season and this new chapter by doing
what I love which is a an interview as
we're looking at each other and if
there's a give-and-take is the door to
Ironman totally closed because I don't
believe it is oh you guys can go through
time now you can go there's there was
you know you already opened up that door
let me ask you the question if I pick
the jersey back up and put it on
wouldn't you feel a little bit like oh
no crap
no oh here's what here's the right thing
they go through a few semi lackluster
Avengers movies without you ready for
this I'm ready here's the scene there's
a moment where the world's fate is at
stake and they've realized they need a
super genius and then they figure out
how to restart that time machine
great come on is that you the audience
sees you when you step out of that thing
is this your and can we you want a
little arc on it too because if this is
your idea then you got to show up for it
too
I'll do it I'll show up what I have to
do I don't know I'll do whatever I have
to do we all have to do whatever Kevin
pie thing they do it's digital I'll hold
that digital thing I'll do it but the
way people would freak out if you came
back hmm come on think about it
take a few years off if you dr.
Dolittle's a couple more Sherlock Holmes
you know it's interesting watching Eddie
Murphy in this last little period of
time and I was talking to Colin Jost
last night who got to sit next to him at
the Golden Globes and who was there and
I'm you know on the show and writing for
him with him when he hosted recently
many go it's just incredible our culture
never encourages taking a break
never encourages saying
don't chase that thing because you've
got it in your hands and and and I love
the idea that if you're you
you're good at what you do then it's not
about time it's about it doesn't matter
when you decide to pick up the mantle
again it's just about but it's scary
isn't it could you imagine like if they
just said hey Joe just don't do the show
for four years and then come back and do
it again you'd be like a lifetime who
knows yeah well with Eddie what's
interesting is he was arguably the
greatest of his era and just stopped
yeah just stop for 30 years and no one
does that
no one who's that good and then when you
see him I don't whew ever saw him he
received some award and he was on a
panel you know and I was sitting in
front of him rather rather and he was
talking about Bill Cosby and he was
doing this routine about them taking
away Bill Cosby's awards okay and it was
[ __ ] brilliant and the timing was so
good in all of us comics were just
sitting there going he could do it
tomorrow he could just get up there
tomorrow and he'd be [ __ ] murdering
yes and but it would be different
it'd be different he's a different human
yeah you know this one of the more
interesting things about it it's him
talking about some of the more
homophobic stuff that he did in the past
now it makes him cringe and you just
can't believe he was that person but you
know he was when he did delirious I
think he was like 22 or something crazy
like that which is just bonkers so he
was not good anyway I've been thinking
about him lately in relation to a bunch
of things but also just that
particularly nowadays giving yourself
permission to not have to jump because
you know as strike the iron's hot all
that stuff exists and maybe it's just as
a bit of an anxiety to the times which I
remember - speaking of past generations
I remember grown up 1974 Nixon's
black-and-white TV getting impeached my
dad and his buddies are whooping it up
but they're still pissed and I'm going
like wow it's it's not worse or better
it's different but now it's on us yeah
so there's the a bit of an urgency and
that that whole thing and just being
able to say like so to answer your
question to me starting up again is off
the table I feel I've done all I could
that character there'd have to be a
super compelling argument in a series of
events that that made it obvious to it
but the other thing is I want to do
other stuff right of course yeah and of
course you know what you're talking
about about Nixon and people get it
people can lose themselves in current
events and what I mean what I mean by
that like it doesn't necessarily
completely your life is more than what's
going on in Washington you know 100
Thompson talked about that when he was
running for sheriff in Aspen he was
talking about how local politics like
your neighborhood
that's real yeah this actually can
affect your life like what's going on in
Washington how much does that affect
your day to day existence it's very
little though for some people it becomes
an enormous portion of the real estate
of their mind it it takes over most of
their day-to-day consciousness where
they're consumed with it and it becomes
a thing they're cheering for or they're
rooting against and and then you know
your life revolves on something that you
have very little power over teams turf
wars yeah
interests yeah think globally act
locally yes it's a beautiful statement
really is it's one of those cliches that
you don't even think about but then I
didn't know that was hunter in that
picture out there to me it look like Joe
Walsh could as easily fit Joe Walsh I
mean he moved to Colorado - oh wow yeah
the Rocky Mountain Way yeah he once told
me he'll speak out of school he said now
honey you should just watch TV for a
year thanks Joe he's probably right
probably right look if you just hung
back and just did nothing but watch TV
for a year the [ __ ] ideas you would
have you'd have you you probably have a
really rock solid idea of what's going
on his was more trying to have enough
things going on but I wouldn't have any
ideas for a year and then I give myself
a break for you maybe that's good to see
you reverently I'm thinking like
analyzed the blends
I think Jo Wallace is one of the most
underrated guys ever because he changed
the [ __ ] Eagles the Eagles were one
thing and then Joe Walsh came around
like victim of love that's Jill Walsh
yeah he came around and just and all
sudden there was a rock to it it's like
they were kicking down doors and light
and [ __ ] on fire it was different there
was an edge to it you know he's he added
crazy he had a crazy - this is a
beautiful harmony and I love it when the
guys that added crazy go up to the thin
veil between dimensions and say I think
I'm gonna stay put yeah and then all of
a sudden they represent stability they
represent being okay hanging up your
guns yeah and just being you know well
that's that's everything everyone has to
accept that at some point in time right
I mean maybe that's you and your glasses
right because everyone has to accept
that at one point time you're gonna have
to get off the ride but when you're
doing great and you're kicking it like
boxers are a perfect example they always
last too long there's only been a small
handful like Andre Ward recently
Marvelous Marvin Hagler in his prime
they just go that's it I'm done and they
actually are done almost every one of
them comes back and almost every one of
them chases that dragon here's what I
love you you're making an argument for
and also the argument against me coming
back and doing another yeah listen I'm
not married to anything except my wife
but I'm not married to any ideas all the
ideas that I have are just like hmm
maybe that idea sucks I love you as Iron
Man so I would I would if you if they
opened up this time machine and you
popped out I just imagine the moment
where everybody goes [ __ ] crazy it
would be amazing to be great I would
love that but I would also love you
hanging it up yeah it's a look it's just
first of all it's 2020 and I'm not an
OCD guy but I keep thinking see clearly
see clearly even if your vision is going
and it's difficult because by I feel
like we all just get buffeted by
feelings and the ego or fears or little
you know chips of resentments or
intuitions that are tied to something
maybe higher but you think is out of
your reach or whatever so it was a
perfect time and I got to go have dinner
with a bunch of the Marvel folks last
night and kind of have just a little bit
of extra closure because you know the
movie came out and it you know was
bananas and the directors are sending me
pictures of like people flipping out in
theaters when Tony snaps and I was like
whoa this was kind of like a really big
cultural thing but then like Victoria
Alonso who's the head of VFX for all
these movies a literal super genius or
Kevin Feige or a Favreau or Scarlett or
some people that I've just have been
there with it for a long time we we we
were there experiencing it all when it
came out and then we see each other on a
red carpet and it's not intimate and
then we kind of hadn't really had a
chance just to do nothing just hang out
and you know have some crudité and kind
of talk [ __ ] so it was really
interesting being here today because
yesterday was this kind of last night
was this kind of real like felt like
closing the circle on things a bit
that's got to be bittersweet yeah but I
like that I'd like that you want to move
on and I like that you want to and I
like that you're doing something like
dr. Doolittle because that's and that
like you've done a lot of wild [ __ ] in
your life you've got a lot of wild [ __ ]
in your career but you sort of embody
every new chapter with the same kind of
energy although there's a different
result and different piece of art it's
all the same you and that's one of the
more interesting things about people and
particular actors because actors get to
be a bunch of different things and it's
one of the weirder things about that
craft like when you see you know a guy
who's like Daniel day-lewis like
embodies these different humans like
literally becomes different humans it's
but it's always Daniel day-lewis you
know I mean like even though he plays
these these you know that there will be
blood guy and all these different
Psychopaths and various fascinating
characters it's always the energy like
you're pumped to see him do
it right and I think that's I feel the
same way with you it's like I know
there's you're an interesting guy
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on in your
head so when you dive into something
whatever it is whether it's your
character from Tropic Thunder or
whatever it is like you're you're gonna
it's gonna be Robert Downey jr. dive in
InDesign so I would imagine it would be
kind of annoying even though you are
brilliant at Ironman to stay Ironman
yeah well fortunately I don't have to
find out right it's it's just
interesting to you know life is doing
something and and you know I met at this
place it's also it it baffles me
confidence what is what does it really
mean there's a period of time where I
felt like I did I did the first Ironman
and then I went and did Tropic Thunder
and then I was doing the first Sherlock
and I had my shirt off and I was doing
Marshall I was like I was all over the
place and it just felt like I was I was
hitting triples no matter what I did
and and then people are like are you
really as confident as you seem and I
was like I guess right now I am yeah and
then and I think this goes I mean this
reminds me we were just talking about
the McGregor cowboy fight coming up you
know it's like it's you gonna go to that
I'm gonna watch it how can you not watch
it you know - brilliant souls who cannot
lose neither one of them can afford to
lose this fight wow that is a matchup
yeah particularly cowboy doesn't want to
lose there's no but there's this guy
who's the the poster child the guy who's
the the one right the chosen one that's
Conor and then this cowboy who's like I
think I can [ __ ] that guy up the
journeyman yeah yeah so confidence you
know there's been times when I felt I'm
in possession of it and then you want to
let go a little bit because it's only
ever the moment and life guiding you the
wind is so at your back there
Wow are you just are you just you know
jumping over the waves and all that by
yourself and you're like you bet I am
but there's a physics to the moment man
moment machine whatever and the wind's
at your back and then the wind does what
the [ __ ] windows and it changes and
if you're left there thinking what you
know so I think it's great to be in full
possession of what you would call
supreme confidence and then see what
happens if you don't hold on to it so
hard because it's great but it is a bit
of an illusion because like everything
else it's always changing and every day
the reset button the spacebar gets
pressed and it's like now what yeah
the reset button yeah yeah you kind of
have to have a confidence to jump into
some of the roles that you've taken
though but I see what you're saying like
that you don't want to hold on to it
because it could come go I remember
Warren Beatty who I learned so many
amazing things from of tuna movie called
the pickup artists with Molly Ringwald I
remember okay and he was kind of the
de-facto producer of it uncredited and
taught me a lot about just acting and
what it was and he said he said what's
your what's your action in this scene
and I was like oh no he's asked me so I
was like my action I'm picking up girls
he does
what's your action in this scene and I
was like I'm driving a car and he asked
me like you know that things sometimes
when someone asks you a question and
just you get caught flat-footed and you
guys know your action is you're trying
to go to work but you're getting
distracted by this addiction you have to
trying to get laid so your action is
you're trying to get to work and I was
like oh yeah he's right and you said
always know what your action is because
then when you come in in the morning
confident or when you're come in in the
morning that can't hit your ass with
both hands you know what to do mmm so to
me one of the great lessons I learned
from him was oh yeah just boiled down
what it is you're doing whether there's
a camera around or just what am i doing
today today I'm showing up and I'm
trying to be
honest and and also to to listen and
learn but really my action today is I'm
today is I'm beginning a process of
promotion Warren Beatty's another guy
who learned how to put his guns down
yeah yeah that's like yeah I think I
remember watching that Madonna movie
remember when he was dating Madonna
truth or dare
yeah and he's hanging around with her
you know she's in the throes of Fame and
everything he's like yeah like he's
never seen it yeah but he's an older
gentleman now he's honest and you know
he's hanging out with her and just
shaking his head and you know that kind
of marked it for me or Warren Beatty
just realize all right let me step away
real quick if I had to talk to him one
things I would ask him is what was it
like when Carly Simon writes a song
about you that's got to be a trip I so
many I mean we should if you we should
do a whole session just about things I
learned from Warren Beatty yeah I'm
telling you I would imagine he's a
brilliant guy clearly do you think that
you could do Tropic Thunder today would
that be possible
oh you could do it and again like Eddie
you know I look back to me that movie to
me was a circle back to my dad's movie
called Putney Swope which I highly
recommend anyone who hasn't seen to see
about a black guy who takes over an ad
agency in the 60s because everyone votes
for him when the head of the company
dies because they think no one else will
and it's about what happens when someone
who is free-spirited takes over and
essentially corrupt endeavor and then he
realizes and confronts his own
corruption but I remember I was probably
two or three when that was being shot
and when it came out and it was so a
part of my upbringing and I just
remembered some of the folks that were
around my dad at that time and so when
Ben called and said hey I'm doing this
thing and you know I think maybe Sean
Penn it passed
possibly wisely and I thought yeah I'll
do that and I'll do that after Ironman
and then I started thinking the system
wait a minute and then I thought well
hold on dude get real here where is your
heart and my heart is a I get to I get
to be black for a summer so there's
something in it for the other thing is I
get to hold up to nature the insane
self-involved hypocrisy of artists and
what they think they're allowed to do on
occasion just my opinion and also Ben
who is a masterful artist and director
probably the closest thing to a Charlie
Chaplin that I've experienced in my hell
the time he writes he directs he acts he
if you had seen him when he was
directing this movie he would have been
like I'm watching David Lean I'm
watching Chaplin I'm watching Coppola he
he knew exactly what the vision for this
was he executed it it was impossible to
not have it be an offensive nightmare of
a movie and 90% of my black friends were
like dude that was great you know I
can't disagree with them but I know
where my heart was yeah and I think that
it's never an excuse to do something
that is out of place and not of its time
but to me it was just putting a it was a
blasting cap on and by the way I think
white chicks came out pretty soon after
that I was like I love that like that
was great so you know well it might be
the last time we see that unless things
change it seems like no one can really I
don't think you could do blackface
anymore I mean we almost lost the Prime
Minister of Canada because he did brown
face
yes pretended to be Saudi Arabian right
you did Arabian Nights in the high
school or something like that
it's it's an interesting and necessary
meditation
on where is the pendulum why is the
pendulum right yeah where is the
pendulum maybe cutting a little into
what could be perceived as as heart in
the right place openness of its time but
again I mean you know there's a morality
clause here on this planet and it's a
big price to pay and I think having a
moral psychology is is job one so
sometimes you just got to go yeah you
know I effed up again not in my defense
but Tropic Thunder was about how wrong
that is
yes so I take exception but no it's I
think you could do it today I think you
could I think it could be done today
there would be so much outrage but there
would also be people cheering and if you
if we got we boiled down all the
[ __ ] and got to the actual result of
what the film did it's [ __ ] hilarious
to this day I watched it again about a
year and a half ago it's a great movie
it's a great fun movie I mean it's it's
ridiculous over-the-top
hilarious and it worked and and your
portrayal I mean it wasn't it wasn't
egregious it wasn't there was it was
necessary it made sense all of it fit it
all the square pegs and square holes I
was just thinking squared I don't know
why I was thinking oh it was thinking
about Sarah Jessica Parker on the ride
over there
like crazy I think I drove by at that
Warner Park near here yeah yeah I think
she went to school over there when she
was doing her show anyway interesting
yeah it it worked and but it was it
might be the last time we'll ever see a
studio take a chance on a guy wearing
blackface and the the prolific use of
the word [ __ ] those are two things and
by the way that's our abend but the
funny thing too was all the heat got
deflected to Ben and simple Jack yeah
that's what people were pissed off about
my golden
great
but you never know when it's gonna be
your time in the barrel you know
sometimes sometimes life just says you
know what and and I've been on both
sides of that coin sometimes life just
says your symbol now did you have
anybody that was telling you not to do
it with their abundance or anyone else
my mother was horrified really Bobby I
am telling you I have it bad feeling I
was like yeah me too mom
but uh anyway how are we how are it
first is that would they put the makeup
on you how are you sweating there's been
a couple times I was all the night
before
I'm gonna run kawaii and I was like well
here we go
and I was just running I think I had six
lines that day but I knew that there was
going to be choppers that was gonna be a
squib fire there was going to be
choreography that was going to be you
know it was gonna be a cacophonous and
the only thing that mattered to me again
what's my action my action is an actor
in this movies to know what I'm doing
even if what I'm doing is insane so I
ran those six or eight lines I had a
thousand times lying in bed over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over again so the next day
I was free to enjoy myself and not be
struggling to wonder what it was I was
supposed to be doing and then that's
what it is it was just you know there
was one little mosaic after the next and
and by the end of it I had some pride
that AI had made it through forget that
it was you know the black face it was a
special-effects makeup day after day
after day after day after day after day
after day except for the times when I
would have my bleached hair and blue
contacts in my eyes or you know other
characters and it was just a it was a
piece of work I was doing and I cared
about doing it as professionally and as
honestly as I could
so when you memorize lines that's an
interesting thing you said that you were
free to
to do it like when you memorize lines is
there ever a part like when you're
acting where you have to think like okay
what am I supposed to say next and how
much does that get in the way this look
I have a very broad band of of
tolerances I don't care if the people
I'm with happen to not know what they're
doing or don't know their lines are
stepping on my lines or or whatever or
want to change their lines and my lines
and it's always a different thing it's
like reading the room it's like you know
if I was a fighter you go into the
Octagon and there they go you ready you
ready and you go and then you just do it
you go in but so I've had it where I
would try to be off-book before everyone
else I would get it down to an acronym
so if there was a thousand words I had
to remember I would just remember the
first letter of each and I would put it
on a piece of poster board and then I
would stand away from it not as far as
you and your your archery set up over
there but far enough away to where I can
see it but kind of can't see it back
when my vision was a little more clear
and I would just run it and run it and
run it when I did the first Sherlock we
were rewriting it so much and I would
have pages and pages of stuff I was like
give me an earwig and it helped me with
my accent and then I started getting
into like you know what's so great I can
finish work go home hang out with my
kids or do whatever I want to do go
train and in the morning they can change
it all they want I don't have to trip if
at all if you know unless it's some
monologue that you want to really be
committed to that's not going to shift
I'm just go like that so you put one of
those little earpieces in and they would
feed you to Lions yeah yeah and now I've
kind of gone as far as you can go with
that and I'll probably go back to a new
method or a new version of the old
method so it's basically improvisational
like you in in the moment you decide
with whatever preparation going to do
for each role how you gonna do it
whether you're gonna go and memorize
everything obsessively or whether you're
just gonna be a little bit more loose
and free with it yes it depends on the
script too like Tropic Thunder Justin
Theroux wrote that script with with
yes really good script I mean my mrs.
who
next to my mother would you know with
I'm probably more so is that the opinion
I was really waiting on and she was
reading in the kitchen laughing her ass
off she goes this is so wrong
this is so wrong and she goes and it's
so true now if you do this right you're
you're doing something that's it's about
a bunch of self-involved idiots somehow
or other becoming heroes and she goes I
love that if that's what it stays and
it's gonna be good and so like for
instance the you know never go yeah full
no by the way I guarantee you I'm
getting out of here my stock is not
plummeting when I leave here I'm not
smoking dope I'm not doing a musk I'm
gonna do everything right stock went up
the next day all right drop six one up
nine with you yeah it just changes it
just changes and I also know that I
don't really know that much and it's
different every time anyway but some I
really like when you have a loose
concept of what you're doing there's
certain parts that aren't going to
change much and the rest you discover so
the first iron man I mean John and I in
there and the writers or John and I we
we were just would write you write a
line I'll write a line and then we would
we were literally watching the puppies
be born as we did it frustrating for
people who not gwyneth because she can
look at a piece of paper and then go
okay I get it and she's got it all
memorized she's amazing
but what's for the highest good
sometimes it's very self-indulgent to
come in and like you know hand out new
pages or say oh I'm not saying that so
feed me that way you know what I mean
you need an environment of respect but I
like I like discovering things how much
of acting is managing those weird
relationships that you have with these
other people that you're acting with
like you you've made some references to
like people changing other people's
lines and
not being prepared I got out of acting
for that very reason that was the thing
that I I went from a world of stand-up
comedy which are just a bunch of crazy
people to actors which are a bunch of
crazy people but in a different way yep
and the managing all the different
characters and all the different
personalities how hard is that that
seems like that could really get in the
way well yeah sure can and it's like a
thumbprint every time you're a new
project it's a completely different you
know fingerprint you know you never know
what you're gonna get and sometimes
projects seem blessed and sometimes you
could say they're cursed but again my
Susan Downey Esquire was talking about
this yesterday she goes it's the only
thing you can't overcome as a creative
producer on a big movie or anything is
in principle no matter what happens you
can fix it we lost the light oh the
Thunder the weather came in okay he got
sick oh she's oh she's pregnant okay
great they changed the costume you can't
overcome personalities
yeah the relationships that people have
with each other do you meet up before
you commit to a role do you ever say
like I want to meet Captain America I'm
find out what the [ __ ] that guy's really
like I mean I love that you think I had
to have the authority did you catch this
guy hurry let me get a taste of I'm
really interested in doing that but we
all have a group dinner yeah these guys
- oh my mo is always let's mine melt
let's get together let's work weekends
let's spend time together because you
can't replace that familiarity but so
you have to try to build it and
sometimes it happens very naturally like
I adore Chris Evans I can't even tell
you why he's a Boston guy he's
technically and it's such a brilliant
actor but he also doesn't take himself
seriously he's flaky but he's the first
guy you would want to have your back if
something went down he's
and and and yet we're different enough
where I feel like by being who we are
and then both having those characters we
were able to I think I thought I thought
Civil War was a special moment in the in
the arc of the Marvel films about
turning one against the other and what
it meant and and so sometimes you just
get lucky as a matter of fact the whole
Marvel Universe possibly without
exception just happens to be a really
well what do you call that when you when
you put together something curated group
of souls mmm well it's interesting
because people take superhero movies
seriously now like now superhero movies
are films that happen to be about
superheroes whereas you know for the
longest time superhero movies were
[ __ ] you know the TV shows were kind
of clunky they were campy you know it
was Batman with the silly pants on and
Robin I bought it everything was a bang
boom that remember you'd see the big
boom absolutely and yet who was in the
first Superman Brandon yes right there
was always a seed of an attempt to
legitimize something that was otherwise
two-dimensional the Superman was
probably the first film that really did
that right and then Batman yeah then the
Batman series but again how many goddamn
Batman's have it been right I'm I want
to see what Pattinson does oh that's
right he's gonna be Batman now I like
that guy we've how many spider-man's
have there been that that's the most
right 3boy3 yeah and three Hulk's right
at least one two three
not counting the TV show well counting
the TV show for the time TV oh you're
right Eric Bana you're right yeah
Norton yep mark Mark Ruffalo who I think
is he's my favorite oh he was just born
for it yeah it's perfect
yeah you believe him yeah and again his
whole thing was what's my action is like
you know
how do you guys manage this giant CGI
thing like how does that work like when
you're on the set that seems like one of
the weirdest parts about acting and some
of those Avenger films is how much of it
is actually digital yeah you just kind
of get used to it um I'll digress it a
movie with Richard Linklater called
Scanner Darkly and it was rotoscope so
great luck a movie I love that movie
love him and then Keanu and I and woody
and Winona and it was this cool thing
and we would shoot these scenes and he
would say oh you can just leave your
your body Mike on the outside because
there's paint the whole thing so that
rotoscoping is a great metaphor for
essentially what the Marvel movies
became when sometimes you would even go
and I'm supposed to come in and like you
know throw something and the it was
off-camera but everything else was great
Oh we'll just move your arm later and
you go wow so you never want to rest on
your laurels and say you know but after
a certain while I was like why am i
wearing this this this football suit
just put some dots on my shoulders so I
can move more freely and they'd be like
all right I go honestly what are you
really using this all this stuff I'm
wearing for it they go for reference I
go great so I'll wear it for one take
and then I'll take it off and I don't
relax a little bit but then other people
would be like or Bettany would be like
I'm stuck in this [ __ ] thing done you
know purple so everybody got to join in
on the joys and the miseries of the of
the the technical challenge of doing it
and speaking of ruffalo by the end
because he's smart hulk
he literally they were just making big
wherever he was and they put a little
you know a piece of PVC with a big Hulk
head up about five feet over where his
head was and he was just there in a
green suit so in a tracking suit with
like his package out you know and he'd
be like let me just at least tie like a
little sarong around mice come on guys
and so I think mark went about as far
out into the ionosphere of fcg as you
can I didn't get the whole smart smart
Hulk thing I didn't get how they how he
figured that out wasn't really yeah like
Hulk is supposed to be Hulk right
supposed to be the alter it's like one
you can control one is one of the the
genius scientists exactly what is the
beast but after so many times and again
this is the genius of the people who
break his shape stories over there Feige
and his team as they go he's Hulk and
he's not hulkees Hulk it's a big battle
always so conflicted what if he could
meet himself in the middle and then what
corner have we painted ourselves in by
having him meet himself in the middle
because then you can't ever if that
doesn't work you can't go back to the
way it was you've done it or you can go
back to the way it was so I just think
that the the real genius of the Marvel
creative team is they and the Russo
brothers who did the last few Avengers
infinity war and end games ago we love
writing ourselves into a corner we love
it because then it it activates all of
those how do we get out of purgatory
juices and then you get the next right
idea now when you guys sit down and when
you first receive a script for one of
these things do they consult with you do
they discuss this with you did they just
lay it out and say this is this is the
character arced how do you how do you
feel about this what do you think yeah
and and but it's changed over time I
think if you're one of the folks has
their standalone movies like Scarlett
has Black Widow coming out I think you
take a I would you take a bit of a
different attack in how much meaning I
think that phrase the legal phrase for
actors and studios is meaningful
consultation not script approval because
then anybody could hold the studio
hostage because I don't approve this
thirty million dollars that you're
trying to spend right
so your schedules fine when you say I
don't approve I picture a bathrobe and I
pictured fine china and teacups that's
how I picture I don't approve and then
just storming off I've had my moments
too because I'm so passionate about
story but again after more seat time
with the same people and new people
coming in and getting a pretty brutal
education on what kind of process these
movies require you you you just start
trusting more that they're thinking on
your behalf and also little things are
easy to change big things become a
inconvenience to the higher good and at
what point do you want to pull the air
brake on something where the the trains
you know already leaving the station
well I would imagine it would be a fine
line that they have they want the the
actor to be comfortable with the
character and they want some and maybe
some feedback would be beneficial but
they're also they have a path the vision
that they've created yeah they would
like to see you somehow or another at
least morph slightly to get on this path
yeah yeah and by the way after I had my
second round of kids with Susan I became
both artistically I had a bit of a
Renaissance when I was doing the third
Ironman and then after that too I was
like well now I'm gonna do this Avengers
and there's so many moving parts and
it's so difficult just to get all these
schedules to coincide and get everyone
together that I'm not gonna be like I'm
not feeling it so again it's that thing
it's a it's sometimes what do they say
faster alone further together sometimes
you can only think about further because
you gotta get downfield
other times you're thinking hey this is
my moment to run and I need I need a
little help and a little approval and I
need a little leeway but that's any
creative endeavor
I would imagine when you're involved in
something that's so epic when it's
actually over it probably almost fien
seems surreal because the production is
so massive there's so many moving pieces
there's so many special effects so many
things that you you
to sort of visualize while you're doing
it and then after it's all over you're
done and what is it like what is a big
Avengers movie how many months are you
involved in this well I mean it could be
some part of eighteen months to two
years depending on how far out you are
and then four to six months of principal
photography and then additional
photography and then post and then I
always include promotion you know from
yeah yeah from soup to nuts I think is
the phrase soup to nuts yeah that's a
Joel Silver phrase one of my uh-huh one
of my great great friends and probably
one of the greatest big movie producers
of all time we did the Sherlock's with
him he did the Matrix series my missus
was running his company for ten years
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang which is I think in
some ways the best film I've ever done
wound up being a calling card it came
out and it bombed and but Jon Favreau
saw it and he said this guy could do an
action movie and so that wound up being
my calling card into the Marvel Universe
but to answer the question it can be
anticlimactic like anything I mean this
is surreal you know I never I maybe seen
you around a little bit but I feel like
I know you because I see you all the
time and I listen to you and I'm a I'm a
a martial arts nut and yeah isn't it
sometimes you when you when you get
outside of the fortunate interesting
creative experience you're having you
kind of go like it's very dreamlike yeah
yeah my whole life is a dream yeah
except for the ramifications the rimsky
those come back a bite in this kid this
is dangerous
yeah I used to I remember the first time
I met Phil Hartman I was stunned
that I was actually like sitting we were
at a stable Reid sitting across from and
I'm like how the [ __ ] you're a famous
guy like you're a really famous guy I've
seen you in movies man
yes you've seen you on television here
you are right there how weird you know
and it seems it's very hard to be normal
and then after a while if that becomes
normal and then the the fact that it
becomes normally comes surreal and then
it really feels like a dream like when I
meet people like you like we've just met
an hour or so ago yet instantly I feel
like I know you yeah yeah it's very
strange but you also you're not full of
[ __ ] you know when someone's not full of
[ __ ] it's pretty easy to get to know
them you say something I say something
back i I know how it works I see what's
going on in there this is actual human
here we go we're talking there's a good
litmus to because you watch your show
pretty clear and I just love it to you
because in your show you literally you
just you start as a rolling start with
you every time you come into the show
and you're already kind of thinking
about stuff so it's it feels very
organic and part of me even this morning
was like I hope he looks into my eyes
and doesn't see a complete and utter
foolish frog because I would probably
believe him if he made that back to me
oh no that's it that's a danger right
yeah if someone if you respect someone
and they think you're a [ __ ] idiot
but there's been times when in just
being myself someone who I respect as
looked at me and said what are we
talking about yeah what are you even
sure and you remember that because it
kind of yeah stiff arms you but part of
those are good because it realized what
you were probably off on a [ __ ]
stupid tangent yeah and that's part of
being a person you know part of being a
person is like I don't know what the
next word out of my mouth is going to be
right now no one ever does unless you do
and if you do is kind of weird
some people are poker players I respect
some people that are that because
there's a an ability to if maybe it's
fear-based but I always appreciate
people who you know as people like their
icons or big shots or that they hold a
certain esteem and all of their texts
are very simple it's like yes yes we
should fix that sure yeah Shores my
favorite
okay on it yeah yeah no periods either
beats the all-caps text oh I don't like
those at all those people weird
although Ct Fletcher he sends me all huh
I love him but he's shouting at
everything everything is a shout yeah
but yeah the surreal part is um I think
part of the reason I'm still so
interested not just in in life but also
you know getting to do what I do is I'm
a fan I love movies I love creativity I
love music I love I love culture and the
fact that I actually have a place in it
while I'm observing it and digging it is
like it's it's it's an honor well that's
a beautiful perspective and that shows
in how you you carry yourself and it
shows in the work that you do that you
do appreciate it you know one of the
saddest things is someone who's in an
amazing position who doesn't appreciate
it and and that that drives other people
crazy to like
prima donnas drive people crazy for a
variety of reasons but one of the big
ones is you don't appreciate how
fortunate you are like and people love
when people appreciate good fortune and
appreciate a well earned position and
are you know engrossed in a beautiful
life of something that they really enjoy
and something that really inspires them
hmm well I I need to I need to be kept
right-sized because I can easily fall
into self-seeking and depression and
self-pity and judgment and all that
stuff it's kind of a it's a bit of a
default but I spend enough energy and
I've had enough help over enough years
to actually just say oh that's that's
just awful destructive behavior you're
entertaining in your head you know bad
patterns just bad thought patterns yeah
yeah we think we could all fall into
those I'm ruthlessly self-critical and
it's for me sometimes it's very hard to
step outside and and just just take a
pause and
and recognize that not everything is
gonna be right the first time you try it
you know I think that a lot of people
that are really great at things it's one
of the things about them is that they're
not very satisfied with their work like
they're always looking to improve it
they're always looking for it to be
better and then that can start that
cycle in their head of self-loathing and
anxiety and anger there at their
performance or their work or whatever it
is that and and then that can lead to
depression and that can lead to just
self hate yeah and what are your
tolerances like that I'll be the first
to tell you like you know do certain
movies or move it in Tropic Thunder or
one of the first you know Iron Man
movies I was like I go over to the
monitor I'd be like play that back again
that was so good
dude let me see that again I need
confirmation yeah because it's always a
miracle you stayed in frame you got the
line right your eyeline was right
the lighting was right the sensibility
was right and you just look at it you go
oh you know it's like I don't know for
me it's like the playback of the perfect
Superman punch ko and just go show me
that again yeah or when we were shooting
Tropic Thunder I had a little teaser
clip for Ironman but it wasn't coming
out until the next year and we were
gonna go to Comic Con and I so I got to
see it and show it to people and they're
like oh I think that's that movie's
gonna do pretty good and then when we
went to Comic Con we saw it but it used
to be like that with music - like I
write music I haven't for some time but
you would write something and then you
just listen to it on the loop because
you go wow that's not I know that I was
here and I did that but it feels kind of
inspired and yeah and you want to get on
that stuff but yes how critical is
important as long as it doesn't bleed
out into and over the edges and just
make it run are miserable right again
get out of your own way yeah again I
mean that's one of the many tenants of
life learn how to get out of your wall
your own way with everything including
with creative endeavors it seems like
that that thing that you said about
music
most people who write things or create
things say that the
it's you they know they're doing it like
if you make a great sculpture you know
you're doing it but where is it coming
from like what is what is the idea that
manifests itself into this perfect thing
that you could step back and look at and
it seems surreal that how did I create
that did I I don't know if I did I mean
I definitely made my fingers move but I
don't know if that's me who wrote that
music who performed it I know you did
but there's a thing inside you that sort
of like Tunes in to this this energy of
ideas and then it comes through you and
again you kind of have to get out of
your own way while you're writing
something and then when it comes out
it's a weird feeling it's not like like
if you hammer a nail into a board you
[ __ ] are very aware you did that
you're very aware but there's something
about the creative process that's not
you're not totally there it's weird yeah
because it is you and it isn't you right
it was you even mean I love it we always
hear it too in sports it's like you know
oh you know you know how to go today
Federer oh I was out of my mind I was
not in my mind it was a beautiful day
and I think you saw the results yeah you
know sure effortless poetic well
fighters talk about that all the time
that like especially a counter shot like
they land something and they don't even
have any idea they're gonna do it and
they did it and then it caused the
knockout it's their training manifests
itself in this one special beautiful
moment where bang this thing happens and
then they see the guy drop and like holy
[ __ ] oh yeah and then they they walk
away and it's the work it's it's there's
so many things involved right there's so
many moving pieces you have to be
working on your own mind to learn how to
get out of your own way you also have to
be like really engrossed in whatever the
activity is that you're doing like
obsessed in love with it passionate
about it and then you have to have the
discipline to show up and actually do
the work there's so many different
moving Pete and it all has to be managed
and it's not solid it's like it's like a
[ __ ] raft on the ocean it's moving
around you're always trying to like
figure out how to keep it keep it moving
and functional it always seems on man
after it's over I was like oh [ __ ]
that even work
yeah we call it the fader board yeah all
right you know how'd he get it all
and honestly particularly in the last 15
years when I started really taking
martial arts seriously
half the stuff that I've been able to do
right in my creative life are principles
that I learned on the mat with my Sifu
mmm you know guards your Center keep
your eye on the lead elbow get to the
Blind Side you know how often you do
that was started I think I'm in 15th or
16th year Sifu was over
day before yesterday so you know a bunch
of times a week and if I'm working on
something or if he can make it the
location will have long stretches where
we're doing it every day and there's
gradings so you got a prep for those you
know mm-hmm it's so what are you doing
you're doing kung fu like is it a very
particular style traditional Wing Chun
really yeah which is very underrated art
form yes also so many trade secrets and
so different than how I see it when I'm
looking at videos and that in UFC
everything is out in the open and it's
discussed and you see and a lot of de
stern stuff there was a turf wars and
we're not really going to show them our
footwork we're not going to do this so
but anyway it's been a real deep dive
with my seafood era quorum whose seafood
my seat gun was grand master William
Cheung renowned kind of hong kong
rooftop fights all that stuff amazing
lore but very technical difficult to
build and easy to use you know it's you
very rarely see that in the UFC but one
of the best fighters in the UFC uses it
regularly Tony
20 Ferguson 20 Ferguson uses trapping
hands
the MOOC Jung yeah he grabs wrists and
comes over the top with elbows he does
straight wing chun he does it all the
time
and he even practices on a wooden wooden
dummy yeah I got my ass kicked by a
wooden dummy for about three years and
then I finally understood the principle
of don't fight for some force and you
know it's just nuts
so anyway half the time if I would be in
a critical artistic situation I would
just say because Wing Chun problems are
life problems life problems are Wing
Chun problems and I would just go back
to how did this kind of relate to
because I don't like getting clocked and
getting my teeth knocked in because we
tend to sometimes we glove up but we're
not wearing mouthpieces it's very well
it's certainly not because he's very
good at pulling his punches and he's
also even better at making sure that I
don't accidentally hit him but we get as
close as we can to what the the real
experience would be but again it's like
everything I'm sure you know a few
clicks back down the road there's things
that instructors were doing that would
be considered illegal to do to a group
of students nowadays yeah for sure
so not just a few clicks while I was
coming out that's what that's what I
would imagine yeah there's students
would get beat up normal you so did you
start training for Sherlock Holmes or
you start training before I did it
absolutely coincided with my recovery
and the two things just somehow or other
seem to to lock in and and talk to you
off the record and afterwards about any
and everything to do with my recovery as
far as it locked him with this it was an
apprentice and apprenticeship and it was
an apprenticeship that was contingent on
me
being in a certain headspace mmm well
it's a good thing too because it's an
it's a
addictive thing people get very addicted
to martial arts and it's a good
substitute for sometimes negative
addictions you know Bourdain before he
died he was obsessed with Brazilian
jiu-jitsu yeah became really obsessed
with it at 58 when and got really good
he was he was training every day and he
was trained twice a day every day so he
went from when I first met him he was
chubby he was smoking cigarettes he
drank every night still kind of still
drank every night but you know he just
did enough to enough healthy things keep
his body together and then his ex-wife
got really into jujitsu and then he
decided to follow her one day to classes
and he was kind of mocking it and
laughing at it at first and then became
obsessed and then really got good I mean
he was and at the the guy wanted a
tournament I mean oh my god yeah he's
[ __ ] 60 years old
what's really crazy is a picture of him
walking down the street and I think they
were in Rome and he has no shirt on and
he's [ __ ] ripped Anthony Bourdain
full six-pack yeah dude he was obsessed
he would take a private everyday look at
him look at that photo that's crazy
hey he's like 60 something years old
there so he would take a private lesson
every day and then he would take a class
so we take a private lesson sharpen up
techniques and then roll yeah take group
classes too which is very very critical
we got a role with different people
how do percentage and so he was in there
like and it became a good thing for him
to sort of become addicted to this
positive thing yeah I mean for me it
wasn't gonna be golf it was gonna be
something passive like that right oh I
hear it's great but it's been it's just
been a great gift and it's also that
thing where you know you're just you're
never done I'm a black belt five years
ago for another grading and now we're
doing a lot of weapons stuff and it's
just awesome
resolutions yeah my tiger window teacher
said something to me when I was very
young they said that it is a tool for
developing your human potential yeah and
I never forgot that because I'm like
yeah it's because it's really difficult
to do like all martial arts or really
it's really difficult to get your body
to move that way and to be able to be
effective in a conflict situation
if you can do it you can do it over and
over again and you can overcome that
difficult thing and you thought it was
insurmountable and then you figured out
how to do it eventually you get to this
point you realized well everything in
life is like that everything in life is
like something it's a puzzle you have to
figure out what how am i approaching it
wrong what can I do to make it better
how do I get more competent at this
particular skill or this particular
discipline yeah and just the humility to
I mean if I've noticed anything in the
last couple of years sitting in UFC
which by the way I was doing a Robert
Altman film called the gingerbread man
back in the 90s and I UFC had just start
off and I was getting the VHS tapes yeah
and watching them and so when they go
back on the 25 years ago I was like I've
been I've been I've been there from jump
that's awesome but we watch it's just
that thing of no matter what you think
the the tides are changing quickly and
yeah and you just got to keep keep
working well that was a real wake-up
call for a lot of martial artists was
the UFC there's a lot of the stuff that
they were doing really wasn't effective
yeah they thought it would be if
everybody was playing by the rules in
the dojo and sort of following along
though but once you really saw actual
caged event where people were just going
balls out you realize a lot of this
stuff just doesn't work yeah well I'd
love how messy it was at the beginning
because the style matchups were so if it
was almost crazy laughable until you
until you saw the violence and no weight
classes if you and I share another
passion resto mods yes yes you have was
it a 1970 Mustang yeah I got that 302 80
of speed core a couple other ones food
court does amazing stuff they're great
yeah and when I saw that they were doing
your cargo oh this is gonna be good
you picked a unique color too yeah I'm
pretty sure that's the only holiday that
thing
yeah that's back east right now that's a
good car for for straightaways that's a
nice long island car mmm
yeah it's beautiful but the beautiful
thing about something like speedcore is
they're gonna take that car and make it
so that it's manageable you can actually
drive it if you drove a real 1970 stock
car it would be it's horrific
yeah and it's amazing how far we've come
yeah those cars it's like you're cut you
like blindfolded as you're driving
you're sort of aware of what what the
car is gonna do is you turn the wheel
but not really know it's it to me it's
like it's like a crop duster without
wings every time I start I just need to
go Jesus Christ I got kids and also
since I threw my hat in the ring with
this kind of green technology
initiatives I I'm probably gonna wind up
auctioning them all off yeah be honest
right you know drove a little BMW
electric car here I saw I and I started
laughing when I saw it I'll hold on to
Forks yeah you have to hold on to that
what you got to what is this that is a
tarantula hawk that Maynard Keenan from
tool sent me from his farm in Arizona
it's uh we were talking about it on a
podcast and he's like if you ever seen
one I go No and then a week later one
arrived in the mail hold on let me see
what this says yeah by the way if I've
been too far off mic this whole time
now you're fine right okay we're good
you could give me a sign Jamie's a
master he knows how to handle this I
know you have a lot of other [ __ ] to do
so I'm gonna I'm gonna let you get out
of here I just want to say it's an honor
honor to meet you know like a pleasure
to sit down talk to you I appreciate you
taking your time and best of luck with
everything just flew by pal yeah I'll be
back trust me okay I hope you do hope
you do come back bye everybody
oh you know what I wanted to get to
there's a guy named brands parent if
you've heard of him
[Music]